ce remue-ménage diplomatiques et
politiques ne semblent guère
impressionné les serbes de bosnie leur
chef militaire le général ratko mladic a
en effet demandé aux autorités de
l'enclavé musulmane de gorazde de
déposer les armes
avant-hier une autre enclave musulmane
en principe sous protection de l'onu est
tombée aux mains des serbes 7,2 g pas
provoquant un nouvel afflux de réfugiés
thierry thuillier
tout s'est bien passé comme espéré des
vieillards des femmes des enfants et bt
tous musulmans bosniaques qui devait pas
en voie d épuration ethnique
l'onu est remarquablement présente
assurant sans faiblir la logistique et
ratko mladic exceptionnellement de bonne
humeur sans doute très satisfait de
l'opération s'adresse aux futurs
réfugiés mis paternel me rassure bonsoir
je suis ratko mladic
vous avez sans doute entendu parler de
moi maintenant vous allez partir comme
le groupe qui vous a précédé
ne vous inquiétez pas zygel sains et
saufs
rien ne vous arrivera merci merci lui
répondent les habitants de ré pas le
casque bleu qui conduit le convoi ne
croisera pas le regard de mladic
pourtant inculpé la veille de crimes
contre l'humanité mais après tout
pourquoi le chef militaire des bosno
serbes devrait-il se gêner alors qu'il
les vainqueurs et que la communauté
internationale y trouve rien à y redire
ce que mladic ne verra pas ce que la
communauté internationale ne voudra pas
voir ce sont ces mêmes enfants ces mêmes
vieillard ces mêmes femmes quelques
heures plus tard à leur arrivée dans les
campements ils viennent grossir le flot
des réfugiés ils sont 5000 eux ont la
vie sauve mais brisée les familles ont
été le plus souvent séparés car
plusieurs centaines d'hommes se cachent
encore aux alentours de l'enclas mais
qu'importe puisque les serbes ont
décrété ce soir avoir mené à terme
l'opération d'épuration et plus kg pas
renvoyant l'onu à son impuissance